48 heures décisives nous dit par exemple
le Télégramme ça passe ou ça casse titre
de son côté elle la voit du Nord et
cette sénateur et les sept députés
continuent de débattre pour trouver un
compromis sur l'ensemble de la réforme
des retraites en cas d'accord un texte
pourrait être voté jeudi au Parlement
l'article 7 a été voté l'article 8
semble-t-il a été adopté par la
commission mixte paritaire et donc nous
avançons et je veux croire que d'ici à
la fin de l'après-midi nous aurons une
commission mixte paritaire conclusive ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui est une forme
de
de prise de prise d'otage des Français
et français il faut bien le dire
huitième cortège parisien qui se déroule
depuis cette question qui est mis sur la
table de la réforme des retraites depuis
5h ce matin ces camions d'une entreprise
privée et leurs éboueurs ont une mission
vider toutes les poubelles sur le
parcours de la manifestation contre la
réforme des retraites qui doit s'élancer
cet après-midi des actions coup de poing
des syndicats comme cette sortie de
supermarché bloquée à Amiens c'est
autoroute coupée près de Caen le hall de
la Compagnie Générale maritime à
Marseille envahi par les manifestants
ils essayent de rouler tout le monde en
faisant des promesses des paroles
creuses et là ils sont en train
d'essayer d'en tortiller les
républicains qui sont là comme une
espèce de de bagages accompagnés qui
attend qu'on les descende du train là et
ils essayent de les rouler à la
commission mix paritaire au final la
mobilisation c'est souffle un peu avec
450 000 manifestants à Paris selon la
CGT mais seulement 37 000 selon la
police si on passe pour le 49-3 s'il
passe pardon sur le parc V3
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ça
va nous ça a posé un problème un
problème de respect de ce qui se passe
dans la rue et de ce qu'on pense que
[Musique]
et bien il y a encore le Conseil
constitutionnel il y a encore la rue il
y a encore plein d'étapes et j'invite
vraiment les Français et les Français à
ne pas te désespérer parce que je sais
que c'est dur il faut que la
mobilisation populaire s'amplifie il
faut évidemment que nous puissions
maintenant obtenir ce rythme nous nous
battrons pour obtenir un référendum
parce que c'est la seule
issue possible démocratique pour apaiser
le climat rendre le pouvoir au peuple
faire en sorte que les Français
s'expriment Éric Naulleau vous êtes pas
la tête maintenant vous faites pas
l'enfant non plus ça devient très
difficile de s'exprimer oh non mais
pourquoi vous dites ça parce que je vous
donne la parole intervenir allons-y on
va pas faire d'enfantillage la
découverte a été faite dans ses archives
de la ville de Florence non la mère de
Léonard de Vinci n'est pas la fille d'un
paysan toscan elle serait une esclave
venant des montagnes du Caucase je vous
le donne je regarderai l'émission depuis
mon fauteuil chez moi où je suis mieux
installé où je porte une tenue plus
confortable Laurent exprimez-vous
il faut se battre pour se parler je
viens pas pour me Bafou pour la parole
elle a été vendue et revendue plusieurs
fois à Constantinople ainsi qu'à Venise
puis elle est enfin arrivé à Florence où
elle a rencontré un jeune notaire Pierre
De Vinci
mais on est bien on est chez mais on est
chez les fous